two months before he died chris farley
returned to host the show that made him
famous it was hard to watch for all the
wrong reasons
in 1995 two years before farley's final
saturday night live appearance new york
magazine published an article titled
comedy isn't funny detailing the show's
dysfunction behind the scenes to make
matters worse farley graced the
magazine's cover seemingly branding him
as the cause of the show's plummeting
ratings the show was facing a pr
nightmare and the only solution was to
clean house saturday night live producer
lorne michaels whose reputation was
tarnished following the article had no
choice but to completely revamp the show
between 1994 and 1995 the show dropped
almost its entire cast including some of
its biggest stars like phil hartman and
mike myers some cast members like chris
farley and adam sandler were fired at
the end of the season the firing of
farley and sandler came as a shock
particularly to the actors themselves
sandler told the daily beast he also
detailed how the two used each other for
emotional support during this time we
got
mad together pretended
pretended we weren't sad and pretended
this
was for the best however farley's time
away from the show wouldn't be that long
although his return would come with
quite the price
farley's time following saturday night
live was the start of a burgeoning movie
career in 95 and 96 he and saturday
night live castmate david spade starred
in the comedy films tommyboy in black
sheep both of which were beloved by
audiences however not all of this
success was appealing to farley who for
years had struggled with his public
image and drug abuse as a result of his
fame according to the new york post
farley was disappointed with black sheep
but nevertheless agreed to it at a
screening of the film in new jersey
farley relapsed on alcohol after three
years of sobriety he returned to rehab
prior to filming beverly hills ninja a
movie his close friends and family tried
to convince him not to make crawley
returned to saturday night live in 1996
alongside david spade to promote black
sheep over a year later on october 25th
1997 farley was invited to host the show
unbeknownst to the cast crew and
audience at the time this hosting gig
would be farley's last appearance on tv
before he died in december 1997.
the opening of chris's saturday night
live hosting debut wasted no time in
addressing his struggles with substance
abuse the cold open features tim meadows
and lorne michael's office trying to
convince the producer to let farley host
michael's is apprehensive about letting
farley back but metals reassures him
that post rehab farley is clean the trio
is also visited by farley sponsor chevy
chase who backs up farley's claim
unfortunately farley's promise to lauren
doesn't last long as the comedian
doesn't show up for his monologue only
moments later instead he's in his old
dressing room flirting with cast member
anna gasteyer tim meadows tries to come
to the rescue as the replacement host
until michaels forces him off the stage
in place of chris rock together metals
and rock introduce farley and they start
the show for his first real sketch back
since being fired in 1995 farley plays
the producer of a morning talk show
called morning latte in this sketch will
ferrell and sherry o'terry's talk show
hosts are hysterical over an anecdote of
farley's character involving an
embarrassing cd purchase he made the
sketch grows increasingly awkward as
farley's producer ted tries to match the
energy of pharaoh and oteri's characters
and chimes in that he also met will
smith over the weekend they seem unfazed
by this news still cracking jokes about
his humiliating cd story the sketch also
contains an iconic sharia terry moment
as she emphasizes pharaoh's italian
translations which of course in italian
means affection no actually it's
abundance
what really makes the sketch however is
farley's somewhat subdued performance
it's refreshing to see the comedian
playing a character who seems almost
frustrated with how over the top he has
to be to earn the affections of these
naive daytime talk show personalities
molly shannon and farley were only ever
on the cast together for half of one
season but fortunately the two got their
chance to shine together when farley
returned to host in the second sketch of
the night shannon reprises her iconic
character mary katherine gallagher an
unpopular catholic school girl the
sketch takes place during a dance at
saint monica's catholic school farley
playing a student named mickey asks the
school's nuns to dance with him as he
doesn't have a date mary kathleen
gallagher on the other hand fawns over
another student but when mary's crush
rejects her she finds herself being axed
to dance by mickey this is certainly one
of the cutest sketches of the night and
an excellent showcase for both farley
and shannon it wouldn't be an episode of
saturday night live hosted by chris
farley without an appearance by the
motivational speaker matt foley the
character originated at second city and
was developed by bob odenkirk based on
an improvisation by farley the original
sketch is often regarded as one of the
greatest sketches in saturday night live
history and the character of matt foley
is easily one of the most famous ever
featured on the show crawley reprised
the character many times while he was on
the show although this appearance would
be his last time donning the iconic
glasses and checkered jacket in this
iteration foley is hired as a
motivational speaker for a spin cycle
class screaming at the participants as
he rips his pants and rants about living
in a van down by the river in an attempt
to motivate them the biggest laugh from
the audience in this sketch comes when
matt foley needs to take a break to
hydrate he pulls out a coffee pot from
his duffel bag and douses himself in
coffee can we continue peddling because
we're all paying for this class okay
shut your pipehole missy though this
sketch isn't as iconic as farley's first
foray with the motivational speaker it's
enough of a crowdpleaser for the
audience
following the sketch is a weekend update
segment of the show hosted by norm
mcdonald norm's tenure on saturday night
live was no stranger to controversy
particularly following a highly
publicized o.j simpson murder trial
unbeknownst to norm the farley hosted
episode would be one of his last
appearances on weekend update before he
was fired though he'd later returned to
host in 1999 as usual norm's jokes
during this episode were divisive but he
was prepared when one didn't go well
that one wasn't very good but
try to laugh anyway because it helps
farley have a little rest
sadly norm's firing would come to pass
only a few months after this episode
according to live from new york a book
about the oral history of saturday night
live lorne michaels was told to fire the
weekend update anchor by nbc president
don ulmeyer at a dinner that took place
the same night as farley's funeral norm
remained an iconic stand-up comedian
following saturday night live up until
his recent passing in september 2021 one
of farley's sketches later in the show
would come to be a historic moment for
saturday night live though audiences
wouldn't know it at the time the sketch
centers on a daytime talk show hosted by
anna gasteyer with her guest played by
sherry o'terry complaining about her
problems raising her baby the baby in
question is predictably played by farley
who serves as a force of chaos on the
show and its audience it only gets more
absurd when tim metals enters as a child
doctor only to have both of his arms
ripped off by a manic farley baby what
makes this sketch such an important
moment for saturday night live is that
according to newsweek it was the first
sketch written by tina fey to get on the
air the future 30 rock star was a newly
hired writer in the 23rd season and
would go on to make history on the show
as head writer weekend update anchor and
six time host
one of chris farley's most popular
recurring sketches during his time on
the show was as a member of the chicago
super fans the characters were often
seen in some kind of pub or sports bar
conversing about their favorite football
team the bears and their head coach mike
ditka when farley hosted in 1997 the
super fans returned for a pre-taped
sketch revolving around mike ditka's
real-life departure from the chicago
bears to join the new orleans saints and
the super fans grip with their crumbling
lives following the loss of their
beloved dick cup farley's character todd
has chosen to reject reality and
believes that it's 1986. fortunately
todd is finally able to accept reality
after receiving a phone call from the
real mike ditka it's a great final
showcase for one of farley's most
memorable recurring sketches at the same
time a bit where farley's character
suffers a heart attack does come across
as hard to watch
despite chris farley's episode being a
welcome return for the saturday night
live legend audiences could tell that
the comedian was in a worsening
condition his voice throughout the
episode was noticeably hoarse after
dress rehearsal which wasn't helped by
his appearance as characters like matt
foley which required him to strain his
vocal cords even harder in several books
detailing farley's life like live from
new york and the chris frarley show
farley's condition backstage was delved
into norm mcdonald criticized the
decision to put farley on an exercise
bike in the mad foley sketch and claimed
he tried to stretch out that episode's
weekend update to give him time to rest
in future reruns of the episode the cold
open and monologue were cut out of
respect for farley understandably the
episode is not easy to swallow anymore
especially for those who knew farley
well in the hours after farley's death
saturday night live writer al franken
stated that he had found elements of the
episode quote disturbing on december 18
1997 chris farley was found dead in his
chicago apartment after overdosing on
drugs and alcohol farley was only 33 at
the time and yet his death wasn't a
shock to his close friends and family in
live from new york bob odenkirk and
chris rock described the last time they
saw farley feeling like his fate was
inevitable others like robert smeigle
described the immense guilt they felt
over not being able to help their friend
through his struggles in retrospect many
of farley's collaborators have expressed
their distaste for farley's career
trajectory one of farley's most famous
sketches chippendales has been
criticized by former saturday night live
riders and cast members for
psychologically damaging farley
self-image in an interview with the new
yorker robert smigel regretted adding
the coffee table smashing at the end of
the original matt foley sketch
one person who has continued to spread
the good word about chris farley is adam
sandler the two were close knit on the
cast of saturday night live appearing
together in sketches like hurley he boy
and lunch ladyland however unlike farley
sandler waited a long time to return to
host the iconic late night sketch show
he finally made his hosting debut in
2019 reprising some of his iconic
characters like opera man the real big
moment of the night came at the very end
of the show right before the cast said
goodnight in the late 2010s sandler
filmed his first comedy special in years
100 fresh which ends with the song
sandless sings as a tribute to farley
sandler reprised the song on the very
stage where he and farley made some of
the best comedy of the 1990s despite the
criticism they received from nbc
higher-ups the song is equal parts
hilarious and heartwarming and the
moment was described by the cast and
crew on the episode as a tear-jerker for
the audience and sandler still it's a
touching moment to remind audiences just
how powerful of a presence chris farley
was and how underappreciated he may have
been at the time
if you or anyone you know is struggling
with addiction issues help is available
visit the substance abuse and mental
health services administration website
or contact samhsa's national helpline at
1-800-662-help
4357